(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is Kizzy, a
black and white ruffed lemur.
She calls the rainforests
of eastern Madagascar home,
and unfortunately, home is disappearing.
Black and white ruffed
lemurs grow up to four feet
and close to 10 pounds,
making them one of the
larger lemur species.
Besides making for a curious look,
their extra thick fur helps
protect them from rainfall,
as water just runs off it.
They are an all female
dominant social group
and live mostly high in the trees
where they search for fruit to eat.
While they don't have
many natural predators,
accelerated habitat loss from logging
has left them critically endangered.
This is the black and white ruffed lemur.